under the cover of Darkness federal
police raided a newly inhabited house in
an exclusive neighborhood of Cordova in
central Argentina their target was the
family of Ecuador's Most Wanted Man drug
trafficker Jose Adolfo masas known as
fetal his wife Mariela masas their three
children a nephew a family friend and a
nanny were arrested and quickly deported
back to Ecuador to be interrogated by
authorities there
we are proud that Argentina was a
hostile territory for a group of drug
dealers who could have come to settle
here Mr feto had a sentence of 38 years
and he escaped leaving a trail of blood
and death in
Ecuador fito the leader of the infamous
chonto crime gang was serving his
sentence for murder kidnapping and drug
trafficking when authorities planned to
transfer him to another facility 10 days
ago they discovered he was gone
fito's escape and that of his main rival
known as The Savage triggered a new wave
of violence throughout
Ecuador on Wednesday a prosecutor
investigating the Takeover of a TV
station by gang members was
murdered I think the whole region not
just Colombia has allowed for this
problem to grow in an uncontrol way we
must stay together to fight this it is a
regional and worldwide problem the
consumption of these products is in the
United States in
Europe the government has declared a
state of internal armed conflict which
allows the Army as well as police to
fight drug gangs significantly Mrs msas
arrived in Argentina exactly two weeks
ago just before her husband's Escape
they' bought the house in cash in
December presumably as a hideaway but
what authorities are still investigating
is whether fito sent his family to
Argent Tina or whether he himself was or
is still in the country Lucia Newman Al
jazer buenos
IIs make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer